you are not tricking anyone people  continue to live life hosting sharing  photos they're so happy and crushing it  having dinner and saying everything's  great my favorite one buying [ __ ] that  they can't afford to make it seem like  they can afford it and living basically  their entire life as if the [ __ ]  that they're trying to project is  actually working think about how many  times you've gone home after being with  three or four friends and have had a  conversation with one other friend about  a different friend who was posturing but  you both knew it wasn't true think about  how the world's currency is actually  working the real obvious thing to me is  if we all knew that the only people you  ever trick are the only people you don't  want to be hanging out with in the first  place i think a lot of things in our  world would change my friends why are we  trying to impress people so much for  what we must really work on not allowing  outside validation to dictate our lives